[Music]
and runaway bride news oh yeah submitted
by juego de luna go ahead a rug fire you
can't get far you can't run that fast
he's still long a bride-to-be is accused
of faking a bachelor party to steal 17
G's from her fiance and his friends and
he still got married I'll be great
that's a lot of money you do that if you
say like I'm booking all these hotels in
your money
Oh Rachel and Chris she looks sweet
though she doesn't look like she steals
she's 29 is 27 well did she go to Hawaii
so they're from the UK how come the guys
in UK look like American guys that are
sloppy cuz we're all from the same place
brother but it's like it's like they're
why people but the sloppy kind you're
offending so many good thing Yuto that
David Beckham all right take it back may
because although all the news that we
care for Jake it's all like the UK
version of white trash yeah I think
Charles looks like white trash really
and he's an inbred [ __ ] they all had to
[ __ ] each other maybe way back a long
time ago
another inbred I think we all are I'm
just against that monarchy so hard okay
baby yeah so Rachel so Chris and Rachel
they've been dating for the past three
years
they were gonna get married around
Christmastime this year but when Rachel
she said that she would take over the
bachelor party planning for Chris and
his thirty friends and here's 30 friends
that's a lot reports that 29 others May
31
I don't know 30 people I don't have 30
friends and I have a lot of friends I
thought yeah so she she said that they
she would book everything for their trip
to Ibiza and she said that she handled
the plane tickets and the hotel
reservation for woman these people they
enjoy collecting all the money yeah so
she collected all the money she gave she
made everyone pay a deposit and then
they had to pay up before the trip boxes
and she made an evacuation oh she made
an evacuation we're doing with
evacuation you say it all the time and
she's dude on the news he was getting
interviewed right he was like well I'll
just here for the show because everybody
getting ready for the evacuation usually
I'm nice and warm on the inside of the
joke but I'll be on so anyway so then
she got about $17,000 she ended up
faking these boarding passes and she
said that she got it from a travel
agency nearby where they live and so she
even faked the entire boarding pass with
the logo of that travel disease even
with the with the confirmation number
and everything with all that work she
should have made more than 17 grand
that's a lot of circuits set up a whole
fake business to do this no they've been
dating for three years yeah so yeah
telepathy
so it's here she made 17 grand yeah no I
mean she probably decided it that was
her exit strategy like she's like [ __ ]
this guy
yeah for this bachelor party for the
past a year so it took a year to do this
why was she why does her his friends
have to be involved with it - that's
[ __ ] up
it's like well [ __ ] you and all your
[ __ ] fans and they're gonna find out
what's the game plan she's gonna like
change her name and change her face and
move somewhere with 17 I'll seem to okay
over that a little too quickly gone girl
over here yeah no kidding hey come on
she's all monitors you can't get that
straight so guilty yeah so the whole
group they showed up to the airport for
their 6:45 a.m. flight and then they
were just told like oh these tickets are
fake like you don't have a booking for
this flight and then they ended up
calling the hotel and the hotel I've
never heard about that [ __ ]
so then that's when they contacted
Rachel and then that's when Rachel was
like I'm so sorry I'm gonna fix it don't
break bro unless you vanished oh my god
this would never ever happen to Mariel
you can never do that to her because
she's a double checker pre-checker
quadruple checker so she had somebody
else booked something she goes okay let
me get the confirmation number so I can
confirm nah that's just how she is as a
person she does that would never happen
Ariel and then she would help me because
that would happen to be easy I might get
it handled and I just go about my day
happen Joe so easy - he let me handle
everything and I'm just like dude you
could just totally get in on TV but you
would at least do that be careful with
her man I know how to double check no
you wouldn't
I know how to double check you would at
least do the pre-boarding booking before
going to the airport
Nikki handled everything yeah wouldn't
you sure like an email like your flight
through yeah you get emails yeah
sometimes I don't even know where I'm
going and think you just think one of
the biggest reasons I can't go back to
being single I don't want to handle
everything by myself
me too we fight that's what I think
about all the time I'm like who's gonna
pay the bills who's gonna oh my god I
gotta wash my car
I need Riven not the fact that you love
her
well that's on the list took a lid my
rooms gonna be a mess oh I can't go back
to that oh dude if i didn't have Nikki
my clothes would be [ __ ] clean what no
she's a [ __ ] mess man no she is cuz
the in fact I just noticed this cuz
she's been on this movie that's why she
hasn't been with us and so I cleaned up
the house the first day she left for the
movie and then it's like the next day
and I'm like wait there's nothing to do
because it's a really clean stuff cuz
you probably just go to the computer
take a [ __ ] and go to sleep million you
don't use any other help I feed the cats
I use the computer I [ __ ] use the
stove real quick or some [ __ ] all right
getting GrubHub and I'm back at the
computer it's like so I'm like I'm
realizing as this is happening on my
holy [ __ ] she's the mess maker dude it's
all her but she gets me to clean up all
the time she's clever dude I just
cracked the code so I'm [ __ ] on dirt
it took me four long years no I'm the
mess maker yeah you're disgusting
yeah really I'm not dirty okay is messy
do leave piles of wherever you go cuz I
can see where that was yeah I could see
where Nikki was because I'm like there's
bunch of [ __ ] coffee mugs everyone he
just brought in a [ __ ] dried ass
banana peel I was sitting in his car did
you see that hey I'm not a litter bug I
have morals okay just scruples yeah what
are that phrase come from litter bug
maybe there's bugs that like each it and
then like throw it everywhere so we I
just mixed it I think it was an
elementary school thing like if you if
you throw some trash and then someone
calls you up hey don't be a litter bug
and then you feel bad and you pick it up
cuz you think they're gonna tell the
teacher no it's my grandma's [ __ ] even
if you lit her food all these bugs go on
it oh maybe I think it was a guy who
[ __ ] [ __ ] up his apartment and his
wife comes home and he and she's like
what happened he's like a [ __ ] others
like a litter bug dude
so anyways back to this story so Chris I
ended up tweeting out my fancy Ibiza
yeah
anybody fancy of these what does that
mean like do you want to anybody wanna
go oh he's British yeah where the [ __ ]
is a visa it's insane isn't it pronounce
it really [ __ ] sweet okay what does
the UK staff yeah I think Ibiza is an
island right yay I know about Ibiza is
my rave days
yeah everyone talked about Beto you got
to go there man it's the place to be and
I'm like I got that kind of money for a
plane ticket but I have money for
ecstasy I know he's racking them up I
know in kind of two after this whole
mess either tweeting well words cannot
describe the pain and feelings that are
playing with my head today I totally
want to apologize to all my fantastic
mates that were gonna celebrate what was
supposed to be my stag do I can't
apologize enough I'm sorry boys I really
feel terrible I would hate to be his
friend that's so embarrassing so then
there were reports saying that the
reason why Rachel did this was because
she found out that Chris was cheating on
her but Chris's friends are denying that
and I mean even if he was why got a
steal from his friend exactly as his
friends they have nothing to do with
yeah they take him out I mean it's not
hard to find her she had he has her real
[ __ ] name yeah maybe well she was she
was in hiding apparently she's heading
in some like mobile home park they
actually triangulate that [ __ ] you know
it's not too hard she's living like a
lady who stole 17 GS six months she's
been disowned by her family her brother
calls her a wooden coat an evil cow big
evil town she got rotten milk yeah
because I don't know it's pretty [ __ ]
up $17,000 and you wanted to disappear
with that that's not very smart yo no
that's like the trade-off is terrible
she needs to do one last heist and get
the real money yeah she retires
seventeen thousand isn't it's a lot but
it's not that much one more time yeah
that's all I'm saying
high dollar target right someone big
that was just the pre this was the
exercise to get to the real one
see he was a dry run it's not for the
big balls I actually would like to steal
some money like I miss I kind of miss
dealing to be honest like sound like a
scoundrel right now but hear me out hear
me everyone says after they say
something racist you got it it's hard to
sympathize if you've never committed the
stealing before right cuz you oh that's
so bad but but okay so if you're if it's
a victimless crime or if the crime is
like spread to like or someone lose
every single person that got Jack loses
like five cents right but you stole from
1 million people but just 5 cents how
good that would would that reduce crime
yeah I'll be like it's 5 cents you could
have it I I'm not mad but then you steal
from some Mexican drug dealer who's like
5 cents
yeah it's the sweet science of my money
[Laughter]
in the 90s like that word there was
[ __ ] his face was it office space
yeah the guy electron we were on the
computer I stole one cent a day or per
account once I'm pro yeah that's how I
counted still money they funnel like
cents in dollars from
yeah dude I saw that I saw that Ozarks
dude they mean he stole like a little
bit of money and but there's there's
also that kind of like intelligent
white-collar crime style but there's
also the straight-up good ol armed
robbery like you can go into a bank and
like hey give me all your money
dude [ __ ] if you [ __ ] hit him in the
face with a shotgun it's cool like
actual victim I know I don't want to
scare people and also I'm just trying to
think of what's a victimless crime but
you get away with millions and you feel
like hey I want a victimless crime is
when you rip that tile off that mattress
yeah that's a big crime I think it's a
crime if it hasn't been bought in Joe
moly it's a crime I heard ya know it's
it's an actual crime isn't it yeah if
you rip off the tag before there's soul
that yeah before it so they think it's
all ruined oh it's for the mattress
store yeah I don't know I hope you guys
enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]